me alright so we're gonna talk about
building portfolio today I've built a
lot of portfolios in my life that's like
what you do in college when you go to
art school so I'll give you a little
quick background on me I'm a designer
I've been working at logistics here in
Oklahoma City for the past year and
we're building some cool stuff and it
all deals with lots and lots and lots of
data so that's what we're doing I've
been designing professionally for about
10 years it's like nine and a half or
something I've surrounded up makes me
seem cooler I've been doing design in
general since 2004 I do know HTML CSS
and jQuery not JavaScript jQuery that's
still a thing guys it makes Mex Carson
really really mad so if you want to get
a rise out of Carson ask him how to do
WordPress and jQuery and he will he will
let you know so I've built portfolios on
paper my first ones were on paper and so
it was like a book and we would like
make these portfolios and we would put
them up on the wall like the pages and
my professor would come around and she
would say that's trash and she'd rip it
off the wall she like you can do better
so that's a little you know you guys
aren't gonna have that level of you like
pressure here I've done flash of how
many of you guys have used flash
Macromedia flash no but am i that old
okay we built it with flash in
ActionScript you know so things were
animated and then I've done them
obviously with HTML CSS and JavaScript
and I've learned one big thing
portfolios are hard portfolios are hard
because you're bragging on yourself so
it's like you're like look what I can do
I'm so great and so they're actually
kind of hard so I put a picture of my
family up there so that's my wife my
daughter and my son my son was gonna
attack the person taking the picture
with the shovel so you know that way if
you come back to this slide later you
know you know you'll remember who I am
all right so let's talk about what a
portfolio actually is because a lot of
times people think I'll just throw up a
website that's portfolio so a portfolio
is technically it's a collection of your
work it's going to show what you can do
it should ideally have a way for someone
to get in touch with you so maybe an
email phone number or something like
that it should also give a little
description of who you are right so
thank kind of along the lines of a
resume like it's gonna give who you are
I would say include as much good work as
you can so don't don't just put
something up there because you have
something if it's bad don't put it up
there and kind of going along with that
focus on the work you actually want to
do so if you're listening to this and
you absolutely hate writing JavaScript
and you like to design do not fill your
portfolio with JavaScript because the
people that come look at your portfolio
are gonna say they're really good at
JavaScript and then you're gonna get
into a job you don't like doing or you
won't get a job because your JavaScript
is not that good that would be my up
case so again portfolios always seem
kind of hard because you're bragging
about yourself you're talking about
yourself but you have to be able to do
that you have to kind of talk yourself
up you can't be like I'm dirt I don't
know what I'm doing because people won't
they'll believe you they'll be like okay
they're not any good so you have to kind
of brag on yourself a little bit so now
let's talk about what a portfolio is not
a portfolio a portfolio is not a blog
nobody cares about your Pinterest
recipes or anything like that that
people put into blogs this is not a blog
so maybe when you get a little bit
further along it can be a blog but it's
not a blog right now it's also not a
collection of photos unless you're a
photographer you don't need photos on
your website it's not Instagram or
Flickr or any of that stuff so you know
keep it keep it kind of focused and next
your opinion on absolutely anything
nobody cares this is like a resume so I
know this is kind of harsh but
technology you know nothing about but
you have opinions about don't do that no
but you will make yourself look stupid
so don't do that don't talk about
religion even if you're religious I'm
religious but I keep that off of there
because people that are like coming to
look at my stuff they may not be and I
might offend them so I'm gonna keep that
off of their politics don't put politics
on there because if you're way over on
the left you're hiring person maybe way
over on the right and vice versa so just
keep it neutral and don't put any kind
of isms on there I've seen this before a
lot in the past
no isms no racism no sexism no
just keep it clean keep it simple
no dankmemes please and no cat photos
because nobody's got time for that see
so so I put that in there cuz you know
that's like ironic okay whatever
all right so there's different kinds of
portfolios you're gonna see out there
photography portfolios typically have a
lot of pictures and almost no text
they're almost always a Squarespace
template with this grid of pictures and
you know it'll be like one word and
that'll be it
then there's the videography guys and
there there's are always like so busy
and so moving you can't keep up with
them and they call those show reels so
lots of YouTube clips embedded in there
there's written portfolios and those are
really boring because it's just lots of
text but if you're looking for a writer
that's what you want there's design
portfolios like mine so those are gonna
be printed or they're gonna be online
lots of pictures some text we usually
use case studies to explain things like
explain why we did what we did and then
there's development and on a development
we're gonna want see some code a lot of
the good ones have code on them so
remember that so here's some good
examples of portfolios and they're out
of order because of the way I opened it
but you know whatever
see if we can look at that that's
awesome let's go back to this okay so
we'll start with this one
Joely thanks Kimberly Kimberly sent me a
couple of examples from the group and
then I have a couple of my friends and
then I have mine so we'll just gonna
scroll through these real quick I'm
gonna tell you why I think they're great
this one's great because he gives us a
little example of who he is right he
gives us some nice just kind of
straightforward what he's done what he
can do he has a link to his resume right
here which is great cuz it's a PDF and
that means that if I'm a hiring person I
can click that link download it and send
it to all the people that matter he also
has a picture of himself which is
awesome if you have a good picture of
yourself put it up there so that way we
know what you look like
next he has his projects and he's got a
pin code and I'm afraid that if I click
one of these they're gonna like mess up
it's gonna like you know nope alright
great so it take it takes me to github
and I can actually like look at his code
so that's awesome okay great
so he's got those then he has a contact
so we have a way to get in touch with
him and then at the bottom
he has like social stuff so find me
elsewhere he's got github and does this
at Code pin no free code camp and then
LinkedIn LinkedIn is a great one if
you're trying to get a job because all
the professional people like to hang out
on LinkedIn and they like they really
like that for some reason all right
we'll go to the next one how do I this
is always a great when it doesn't work
the way I wanted all right this is my
friend Justin Justin batten field
he started off life as a freelance
WordPress developer or something like
that and he worked his way up and then
he was the lead front-end developer at
Life Church for three or four years and
then he came and worked at at max and
now he is like VP of product or
something at TBS factoring his portfolio
is really anorexic you can get a hold of
his resume up here his work is contact
his work will just take you I'm pretty
sure it takes you to dribble yep and you
can just scroll through dribble and see
everything he's done and I can't work
Chrome apparently so he just gives you
like a really quick little blurb about
himself download his resume and then he
has Twitter LinkedIn dribble and email
so next we're gonna her about Clint
Clint McManaman this is one of my heroes
he's been in the design game since like
2002 so right now his website is pretty
much just this straightforward deal but
if you click here it takes you to his
portfolio proper and he uses case
studies to kind of show a lot of the
things that he's done which he's done a
lot of things so I like his because it's
just really clean it's really
straightforward he gives you a headline
that explains pretty much everything
he's all about if you follow him on any
social media that's what you're gonna
get so he's pretty straightforward and I
like that so if you'll notice like
things are really simple they're really
kind of just straightforward and I know
these guys are mostly designers and then
we have a maiya
right yeah all right zach is that
embarrassing to like have yours like
thrown up there all right now I really
like this again you give a really quick
just what you can do
you're not like reaching out there and
saying you can you know operate
Microsoft Office or something which is
I've seen that we have a great little
gallery of projects and then we have
them over here on code pin which is
awesome because this proves to me that
you did this it's on code pin so I can
go see what you've done this it's
awesome and then we have and I like this
resume download the resume but we also
have the certificate so this gives
validity to the claims that you're
making that hey I have a certificate
that proves that I can do what I say I'm
doing and we have contact information so
there's there's a few examples I'm going
to go back over here now oh I guess we
can look at mine I just went through
mine and rebuilt it so I love the
mountains so I have mountains I have a
blurb about my professional self and my
personal self I have a little section
about what I do and I have three big
projects that I've done I'm gonna write
case studies for those later and then I
have a little chat forum so when's kind
of anorexic but there it is alright so
if we come back here technology so great
when it works all right so my thing that
I would say is remember to focus on the
job to be done rather than the style
it's really easy when you're trying to
represent yourself to like hung up on
how things look or whatever like
remember that the people that are
visiting your site have a job to be done
and that is to learn about you and to
contact you so remember that and make
sure they can easily do that alright so
let's talk about the building blocks to
include to make your portfolio awesome
everybody wants to do that right alright
so include your work that's gonna be
really important it's not a portfolio if
you don't it's just like a little
webpage so give me work that you've
completed right you want to make sure
that it's done that you can show it off
maybe try some work that
maybe it was something that was really
hard and maybe you can explain why that
was hard and how you got over it maybe
try some work in progress like if it's
okay with your employer or if you're
just doing things on the side you can
put work in progress and you can explain
where you're at and where you're going
you want to do work that showcases your
skill so like the skills that you're
focusing on that's what you want to show
like I'm not gonna cram my portfolio
full of code because code is secondary
to design for me so I'm gonna go design
something and then I'll code it and I
don't really care how the code looks
well I care but that's a different talk
so make sure you also do work that you
want to do again if you I mean focus on
what you're after right don't don't
focus on things because I said to do it
or because Daniel said to do it and
especially if Carson says to do it
no I'm kidding guys Carson is great I
just had the vision I just had to give
him a little big but yeah put work you
want to do on there like if you're like
I said if you want to focus on UI UX
then go figure that out if you want to
focus on development go figure that out
if you want to do like machine learning
go figure that out you know focus on
what you want to do bu right so try to
put your best foot forward with your
work you want quality over quantity
you know show them what you know what
you're doing
I would say quality over quantity
because I don't want to scroll through a
bunch of stuff that doesn't look very
good that isn't complete that you don't
really care about I'd rather see three
things that you care about then ten
things you don't all right so show your
work that's the next one consider using
case studies so that is a like laying
out and saying this was the problem
this was our essentially our hypothesis
this was how we approached it and this
is the results that's really good
because it shows the thought process
behind it not just a copied code from
here and pasted code to here and it
worked I don't know why you want to show
why explain the technology stack you
used you know why why did you use react
overview or why didn't you use WordPress
when it was a CMS or why did you use
whatever you used explain why instead of
just saying
I use these technologies and putting the
cute little icons like great you use
those use those on every project why did
you choose that explained problems you
ran into so like if you're working on
something and you had a problem and it
was essentially a showstopper how did
you get around that did you ask for help
did you stay up till midnight trying to
figure it out how did you solve that
problem the reason I am stressing this
one is because it demonstrates that
you're a problem solver and not just a
you know hanging out on Stack Overflow
which is sort of problem solving in my
case but it shows that you know what
you're doing and you know how to go
beyond just the specs you can actually
get out there and kind of solve problems
so think about soft skills demonstrating
those like who did you have to talk to
you to get the specs like how did you
figure out what the problem was
that you had to to accomplish these are
these are like soft skills that a hiring
person's gonna want to like hear about
and I wouldn't say like list them out
like a bullet point maybe it's how you
describe the problem and like maybe the
problem was you know we my company
acquired this job and I was required to
talk to these people and then I had to
talk to this person to figure out what
the users were after and therefore I
chose this technology stack and we ran
into this problem and this is how we
solved it and that's all just in a short
maybe couple paragraphs you know and
then you have screenshots and maybe some
code pin embeds show in the code and
that's just an idea you might also think
about explaining how you organize your
work how do you organize your tasks you
know like what kind of what kind of
organizational system do you use that
shows that you know how to organize your
life and you're not living out of a
suitcase there's nothing wrong with
living out of suitcases which employers
don't want your code that way cuz it's
really hard to come back to alright so
think of your portfolio as a resume with
some personality I know a while back it
was really cool to do like these little
catchy rez like portfolios that were
full of trendy verbage but people aren't
really after that so do include your
resume someplace to download like I said
hiring people want to download that and
they want to share it with the people in
their group I'm the people that matter
do include a link to something like
LinkedIn that's a great place to send
people for professional stuff they love
it do give us a little about section so
we can learn about you that's a great
idea so that you know I know you're a
real person and you know not just
something thrown up there I would say
keep it professional but add just a
little bit of your personality I mean
think about kind of colors do you like
what kind of pictures do you like what
kind of how do you word things I mean
don't you don't to be a robot you gonna
have some fun with it like it's not it's
not like a science experiment or
something you wanna have some fun so
give me a way to contact you and you
would be surprised how many people
forget this piece like if you're putting
portfolio up there and your goal is to
get a job or get side gigs I need a way
to get a hold of you and a lot of people
sometimes forget that and well that
sounds silly but make sure you have an
email I would say have a phone number
but when I had a phone number on my
website I got so many spam calls so you
know if you want your phone number
that's fine
social media is fine but use it with
caution so I have a note about social
media and this is coming from me
observing other people keep your social
media private so that it's your social
network and not the world but if you do
want to share with the world keep it
neutral so maybe if you're gonna put
your Twitter on there and you're a
religious person don't put a ton of like
opinionated religious stuff on there and
if you're a political person don't put
your political ideas out there I mean we
talked about this a second ago and I'm
stressing it for a reason don't put any
illegal stuff you know if you're out
smoking big doinks in Amish we don't
need to see that especially if you want
a job put no isms again no racism no
sexism none of that please don't even
give your opinion on it because you can
assume if you put it on the internet if
somebody's looking to hire you they will
find it and you can assume that if it's
borderline offensive it will offend them
just assume those things and also assume
that if you put it on the internet it
will never ever ever go away and
come back to haunt you in 10 years just
assume those things they may not be true
but assume them because people are going
to search for you they're gonna Google
you they're gonna do all sorts of stuff
they're not just gonna look at your
website and go that was cool let's hire
them they're gonna they're gonna dig
into your past so that's what they do
all right here's a few things to
consider as we kind of wrap up and these
are just my opinions
so whatever consider who your end-users
gonna be and this is where I always
start who you gonna build this for is it
for somebody who's going to be employing
you either as a contractor or as a job
are you building it for your peers kind
of like the people in this room is it
kind of just to show off what you can do
are you just building it for yourself
just to have something all three of
those things are gonna have different
outcomes when you're done building it so
as you kind of identify who you're
building it for think about where
they're at right now like what kind of
position are they in you know if it's a
it's a hiring person they're gonna be a
kind of a they're probably gonna be a
business person they're gonna be kind of
coming across your site you know at work
so you can think about that think about
their background because that's gonna
give you a really big idea into what
they're expecting so if they're if
they're this gentleman on the right that
likes haha business he's gonna expect
certain things whereas if it's me I'm
gonna expect something else from your
site so if you think about who is gonna
be coming to your site and you're gonna
think about what their background is
you'll know kind of how to you know
tailor your website to get the result
that you want all right so again kind of
diving more into that what is your end
user looking for what kind of position
are you going for you're gonna be a
developer a leader or you just a haha
business person and those people
seriously exist
they run meetings and they they go to
meetings and they talk about meetings
and they talk about getting stuff done
and they have meetings about getting
stuff done and they never actually do
anything but they love it so what kind
of position are you going for and you'll
kind of want to tailor your site for
that again think about what what's their
job to be done when they're coming to
your website what are they looking for
are they looking for your work or are
they looking for you know what are they
looking for typically they want to know
about you and they want to see your work
and then the name one
be able to contact you if they want to
and you're looking at maybe 30 seconds
before they make that decision if you're
lucky so why would these people be
visiting your site is it because you
applied for a job is it because they
just saw you in a forum somewhere is it
because you you know I taped it to their
door I don't know I wouldn't do that
it's QR codes or they're not cool
anymore all right how did they find you
did did somebody pass them your website
was it like you know like in a chat and
they copy and paste it check this out
did they find you like through a user
group type thing I mean these are all
going to kind of dictate you know how
they approach your site so I would say
have empathy for your end user and make
it really easy for them to find what
they're looking for because you're
helping them like you if you do that
remember that they have a job to do and
they want to do it quickly nobody wants
to hunt for things even if you think
it's clever they don't so make it easy
for them to find what they're looking
for all right and finally just remember
your portfolio doesn't have to be
perfect
I've struggled with this a lot in my
life and a lot of people have talked to
you especially when I remember when we
were in college it had to be perfect it
doesn't have to be perfect build it to
your current skill level if you're
trying to be a developer and you can
only write HTML and CSS that's fine you
can build a portfolio just build it make
sure it gets out there keep it simple
you don't need a ton of like fancy
animations or fancy effects or whatever
just keep it simple remember what you're
trying to accomplish with it and make it
easy to use but have fun doing it that's
the other thing like if you want to put
some some fancier things in there to
kind of show your skills and have fun
doing it
that's fine too just don't feel like you
have to number one thing is get it done
because like a resume this is kind of
like the you know the electronic resume
essentially like you were putting
yourself out there and saying Here I am
this is what I can do so if you feel
struck at all I put this quote up here
this cool it's been really big for me
lately
it's my Marcus Aurelius the Roman
Emperor he says the impediment to action
advances action
stands in the way becomes the way so
building a portfolio is hard because you
have to brag about yourself you have to
handle writing all the body copy for the
website you have to think about doing
this and that and it has to be
professional but it makes you a better
developer and a better professional for
doing it by right all right does anybody
have any questions in anybody yes
right okay she's asking for me to repeat
talking about case studies specifically
like what goes in to case studies case
studies typically highlight a project
you're working on so let's say you were
building a project and you had to make a
form for the first time right so you
were you were responsible for building a
form that took in a certain amount of
information and sent it somewhere so you
wouldn't highlight the whole project you
might say within this project that I was
working on at work and you might give a
little bit of background about the
project you would say my task was to
build this form and so you would say I
started by researching the forms and we
we came to figure out this was what
information was needed you know maybe
was the person's name an email and a
short message this is really simple and
so you talked about how you had a
certain technology you're using and you
had to go figure out how to pull those
things in when the form was submitted
and you had to talk about how you
capture that that stuff in the database
and like alerted whoever needed to be
alerted and so along the way you can
talk about then you can put in code
snippets you can put in screenshots you
could put in screen captures like video
and then you can kind of elaborate into
the results so like maybe the results
were because of this people were able to
ask for help which increased
productivity X percent that's typically
kind of what you see on most case
studies and I'm coming from a design
background a little bit so it is kind of
like problem solution the result is kind
of what you can boil that down to was
did that help did I answer your question
great anybody else
No
oh oh go ahead no you're fine it's
Daniels go ahead
mm-hmm
so she's asking about like and you can
correct me if I'm wrong you're asking
about keywords and extra work is that
okay so she's kind of asking about like
keywords and and having more than just
what what's on your portfolio so
keywords
I don't really know about that's kind of
like black magic to me that gets into
like SEO territory which is not
something I very familiar with but as
far as having extra work yes you will
want extra work for an interview
I would say on your portfolio online
maybe putting your best foot forward but
then having somewhere maybe github maybe
code pin if you're into the design maybe
dribble or Behance
someplace where you can stash other work
and it's not that that works bad it's
just that you haven't chosen to
highlight it as quote case study because
case studies take a lot of work like you
really have to kind of dig in and think
about why you did what you did and you
have to go track down and the results
and stuff like that so they actually
take a lot of work so maybe it's not
that that works bad and as much as it's
just you didn't want to do that you know
what I'm saying so yes when you get into
an interview people are gonna want to be
able to see the different skills that
you have they're gonna want to see
different types of work that you've done
and they're gonna see that you're
flexible and they're gonna want to see
that you can problem solve and so by
having more work to pull out and show
that might not be on your website you
show just that so did that answer your
question
yes
that's a really good question and that's
a really hard question I would say at
least in my case what I've done is I've
either asked the client and said is it
cool if I show this in all my portfolio
and you you know you can if you can
demonstrate to them a lot of times that
you're not gonna give away any trade
secrets or anything like that they will
a lot of times say yes if you ask them
if not the other thing I've had to do in
the past is to essentially recreate the
project by changing enough stuff that I
can so that it's basically not that
project because really what you're what
you're trying to say is here's a problem
and here's how I solved it and so if
it's a fake company and fake data
you're still solving that problem and I
mean you can X probably in an in an
interview you can explain your situation
and they're gonna be they're gonna be
cool with it you have to be creative in
how you solve that problem because
that's a problem in and of itself
anybody else
where's the happy medium the happy
medium is if you can look at the website
and say it communicates what you want it
to communicate so if you need a header
and a picture and one paragraph tag
you're done you did it you know maybe
you can get in with a few extra stuff
but the I've heard this over and over
and over again and I always kind of
struggle with it because nobody wants to
follow it but the rule is this nobody
reads anything on the Internet I mean
think about it when was the last time
you read you seriously read anything on
the Internet I mean and I'm not talking
about like you you saw an interesting
article you chose to read I'm talking
about as you browse the Internet
somebody sends you a link what's the
first thing you do you scroll you look
at headers you look at pictures and if
it's interesting you might read the
first sentence of a paragraph so that's
how people typically consume websites
and you have to remember that like if
someone sends my portfolio to a hiring
person they're not gonna read it until
they think I'm interesting they're gonna
scroll through there they're gonna find
my work and they're gonna go look at my
work and they're gonna go yeah this is
not what we want or oh that's so perfect
that's what we want and then they'll go
back and read it and if they decide they
don't like me they probably just
couldn't close the tab and that was it
so the happy medium is saying I want to
communicate this message and this is
what it takes to do it and when it comes
to writing I've always heard you want to
keep it about a sixth grade level and
you want to write out your message and
then rewrite it and then rewrite it and
make it as simple as possible you know
and then basically whatever you have cut
it in half and rewrite it again because
that's how writing goes and that's why
I'm not a writer cuz it's kind of hard
but there's tools for that but does that
answer your question or awesome anybody
else
from twitch
how would I show a portfolio in a
portfolio a project I'm working on with
someone else set
oh I didn't do the entire thing okay I
would highlight the pieces that I did do
and I would not be shy to say I worked
with another person or you know maybe
even name him if they're cool with it
and I would basically say I worked on
this piece and then so-and-so worked on
this piece and then I took it back and
worked on this piece and you know you
that's actually really good because it
shows that you can work in a team
environment and that you can communicate
you know back and forth and pass work
back and forth
see
[Music]
so you're asking about what do you do
with like skillsets so like if you have
a bunch of different skills how do you
demonstrate that okay I would say like
in a development environment it's
probably okay to list out I know these
languages because that's really one of
the best ways to show that but if you
can back that up with some projects and
be like in this project I you see sharp
and in this project I use JavaScript and
this U in this project I use PHP and if
you can like demonstrate that that's
even better because then it's not just a
list of things that you quote no it's
actually demonstrating that you know how
to do that I typically don't list out
skill sets because in the design world
it's kind of become it doesn't matter
it's like oh you can read some code and
you can do wireframes and you can do
mock-ups so that's it and my portfolio
already demonstrates that so it's like I
don't have to do that so that was a
great question yeah I would actually
probably list those out somewhere
it's it's a it's a static webpage I used
dribble to host my work and then I
linked out to that I used Jekyll and it
works with github pages so it's like
free hosting so you make a gh-pages
branch and you push your code up there
and then it point the you buy a domain
name and you point it to that dns and it
works so so yeah it's static I don't I
don't do much in that way you were gonna
ask a question
so you're totally asking let me see
you're asking if I use Behance as a and
dribble as a supplement or as my
portfolio right okay I actually use that
as my portfolio both of them now have a
feature where you they like make you a
little webpage and so I built the
webpage that I showed you guys let me
I'll pull it back up actually if I can
figure out how to work Google Chrome cuz
apparently I don't know how to work
Google Chrome
there we go okay so I built this page
and then all of these things link to
dribble and so I've created dribble
projects and then in the descriptions I
talked about what I'm doing there and
why I'm doing things and then you have
all the different things and then when I
say see more work that just links to all
my dribble feed so there's a lot of
things in here that are not too bad but
I didn't put them in there as a case
study just because it didn't really
matter to me so that's how I'm using
that and that going back to your
question that means because I'm using an
outside source I don't have to use a
database and I can just use a static
page to just host some information so
yes oh sorry you want to see the project
right
I'm actually I don't know I want to make
case studies I haven't done it because
they're time-consuming so I've put these
you know I have basically my last three
major employments and I have examples
from there from things I'm doing so this
is stuff I'm currently working on and it
and inside of this stuff here it kind of
explains like each post I'm explaining
what the post is about and like what
what kind of problems it's solving so
it's sort of a case study but it's not
like a traditional case study I think if
you were to read through that you would
actually kind of get a grasp for what
I'm talking about
like what's what what the what the the
picture actually means so I should
probably do a better job of actually
making a page for case study but I was
lazy and I have a lot going on so I just
liked the fact so remember that I'm a
designer so everything is about the end
picture and showing you how I got to
that whereas if you're writing code it's
about how you built that thing so there
is there is kind of a difference there
any other questions
yeah
nope
that's a good question I tried to get
Stuart Hinds calm and a realtor in
Amarillo Texas had it and I was really
upset and so I got Stuart Hines about me
and that's how I chose my domain name
sorry I don't have any DD references
Daniel back there all right is there any
other questions nope I'm sorry yeah
you're asking what I used for my contact
form it's called formely and it's form
ly or something I I don't know I just
typed in contact form for static website
and there was like two or three and I
picked formally because it was open
source and free so I don't know how well
it works it works when I submit one
myself so I guess we'll see I guess
everybody can go spam it right now and
send me emails and we'll see how that
works
that'd be kind of fun any other
questions
oh so you're asking about like when I
said don't give your opinion on
technologies all right I'll explain that
a little bit further oh go ahead sorry
right
the only reason I say don't push your
opinion on things is because your
opinion is a lot of times what I've
learned your opinion and so while your
opinion may be right most of the time it
might not be right all the time and you
may offend someone wanting to hire you
or work with you just by your opinion
and you may never even know it because
they were reading your blog and they
were like oh he's so opinionated about
this one thing that I just can't get
over I mean it's silly but it's trying
to take that path of like least
resistance because as soon as you try to
say that you know about something people
are gonna come out of the woodwork to
tell you you don't you know and it's so
it's just like when I I always look at a
portfolio like a resume kind of so it's
like I'm trying to be as neutral as
possible but if you know a lot about
something and you can prove you know a
lot about something then go ahead I
would say by linking to something like
having a medium account that's kind of
become the new like blog platform and
like just linking to that off your site
would be fine if you like to write about
tech but I've seen a lot of people and
myself included when I was younger just
giving my opinion about stuff and then
when you look at it five years later
you're like man I was dumb it's like or
you read somebody and you're like yeah
you're a total noob you don't know what
you're talking about you know like so
it's like you want to just be really
careful when you put your opinion out
there that's all that's all I mean by
that it's might have seemed a little
strong but
yeah yeah I think both of you ride on
that she was saying you know that a
company may see that you were writing
about something and decide you were
totally stuck on that one thing and he
was saying if you write in a neutral way
then it'd be okay and I think you're
both right on that like you know just I
don't know just be careful when you're
posting your opinion is I guess I guess
the some of that all right anybody else
got anything nope all right so good luck
making your portfolio's and I will see
you next time does somebody have
announcements okay
[Applause]